[Music]
[Applause]
actor comedian screenwriter musician
producer john c reilly speaking of the
lakers winning time the rise of the
lakers dynasty airs new episodes sunday
at 9 00 eastern on hbo also available to
stream on hbo max and john c reilly
joins us now you know you're from
chicago how much pressure is there on
you to be a chicago or be a laker fan
being from chicago
well
you know i haven't got a great answer to
that question
i followed phil jackson
so when phil left the bulls i was like
all right i'm going with the sensei and
uh luckily he went to another great team
how big of a bulls fan were you
uh you know to tell you the truth sports
in general like i get interested in
sports when i know all the characters
you know when i understand the drama of
the moment and i understand what the
backstory is when the
you know i'm not a great early season
fan
in other words
but when things get hectic and you know
exciting and i know what the
personalities are then i got really
involved so
yeah i was doing plays in chicago when
michael jordan was was winning all those
championships
and we were i remember doing this uh
streetcar named desire
at steppenwolf
and we were running off stage to the one
tv in the green room to like get a
little a little hit on what was going on
just seconds before our queue like
running back on stage
and then i heard rumors that when we
were doing that play that like some
husbands in the audience were spotted
with earphones
[Laughter]
did you ever meet jordan
no no well that'd be like meeting
superman like
not that likely in my life but
that would be cool
do you have to meet the lakers people uh
before you you play them obviously you
couldn't meet dr jerry buss but the
other characters did were you able to do
that and would that help in the in the
role
you know
i don't think it would have helped
actually because what we needed to do
this show was the freedom to interpret
the story as as we might imagine it
because there's so many blank spots in
the official record of what someone was
thinking or what was actually said in a
room you know some of these people are
not with us anymore like you mentioned
um
so
you know i read recently where magic
johnson said like how can you do the
lakers without lakers without the people
who are involved
and i kind of feel like well how could
you do the lakers story with the lakers
because every single personality in that
group is going to have a different
perspective on what really happened
at the end of the day we felt like
um this is an amazing story
these people were incredible
we're not out to like take anyone down
or like you know
focus only on the scandalous parts of
their lives
we want to tell the whole crazy picture
of this season from 1979 1980 you know
it was a miracle what jerry buss pulled
off i mean so many setbacks along the
way as you're seeing as the show rolls
out
um
yeah so
long long story short i think we wanted
the freedom to be able to
look at the
the less attractive parts of these
stories what are you trying to capture
with dr jerry buss
well he was an incredible guy you know
like from his story from when he be you
know when he was a kid in rural wyoming
raised by a single mom in the depression
like
to becoming the king of l.a the
undisputed king of l.a for
so long
um and then all the all the incredible
steps along the way like becoming like a
savant at poker being a math genius
getting a degree in in chemistry getting
a masters in chemistry getting a
doctorate in physical chemistry
you know dan i was kicked out of
chemistry class in high school
i i voluntarily surrendered let's put it
that way
so
you know every time i thought like every
time i would kind of get lured towards
the more kind of um playboy aspects of
his life or whatever
i would have to remember wait this guy
was a doctor of physical chemistry he
was so good at it he could teach it so
what i wanted to do with dr jerry buss
was pay honor to that for all the things
he accomplished not just with the team
but who he was he's john c reilly the
show is winning time on hbo the rise of
the lakers dynasty a new episode sunday
at uh 9 eastern on hbo did you think
about keeping the hairdo
you know i was surprised that comb overs
work as well as they do i must say it
looked pretty good looks pretty good
and in the show
there's a scene where you see me you see
me do it you know you actually see me i
wasn't doing it myself every day at work
and an amazing hairstylist
uh mia who was helping me every day but
i don't know
yeah i mean from the front
it really looks convincing like you see
the hairline like yeah that works for me
and then everyone said you kept it
looking on the side like yeah
but i'll tell you what jerry busted his
own hair every day is the rumor
uh he never you know
had a hairpiece or a stylist or any of
that stuff he just did it himself and i
think and we should we use it in the
show as a kind of point which is that
you know he believed in creating his own
realities
and uh the hair was just you know one
perfect example of that what do people
say to you on the street
if you're in l.a walking around new york
these days they're screaming i love you
dr bus which is
okay
a little surreal you know like this was
a real person like
i guess i'm just sort of a vessel right
now for that
for that love because he was a beloved
guy you look at that memorial of his
and what people said
um
that just tells you everything you need
to know about what kind of guy he was
he's so beloved um
but yeah
prior to that
it's actually a nice break from from
hearing boats and hoes
you know
hearing i love you dr bus is pretty cool
right now
uh your first movie role you were you
were in a steven seagal were you a you
were a tough guy in a bar oh that that
is that's fake news somebody just added
that
i was thinking oh my god i i've watched
all segal movies i don't know how i
missed you as a thug there john whoever
whoever put that on my id
is having a big laugh right now because
they pulled it off they got people in
the press to say were you in a stevenson
movie you know no offense to steven
seagal but i was in college in 1988 i
was not even in the acting business yet
how about opening night next year lakers
you come in full character dr jerry buss
you know
i thought about i was just thinking
about this because i went to two games
recently i saw them play the pelicans
and i saw them play golden state when
lebron got 60 points against golden
state it was the night before the show
came out and i you know i'm sure they
have other worries but part of me was
sitting there thinking like
i wonder because i heard lebron likes
the show i wonder
if he's sitting in that locker room
tonight thinking we are not
having this show come out tomorrow night
and have everyone say yeah but they got
killed by golden state last night so i
think he like he was like guys i don't
care what happens with the rest of the
season we are winning tonight you know
the ghost of dr bus is sitting there
uh and then he did they crushed it what
an exciting game that was but i was just
thinking recently like about i love
going to games you know and that's one
of the things when you're in a popular
show or movie like they let you sit on
the court side seats so i was thinking
wouldn't it be cool to go to a game
while we're shooting the show you know
and then i thought well you'll have the
mustache
you might i don't know like i wouldn't
want to go and like have people
i wouldn't want to like go and do an
impression of jerry buster i wouldn't
want to like i wouldn't i wouldn't
disrespect their family in that way okay
that's fair it's still it's only 2014
that he passed away you know these are
people that are living with the reality
of losing their father so i i don't see
it in that cheeky way and all through
the playing of the character even when i
did crazy stuff as the character i was
always feeling for the family thinking
well i hope i hope this is okay for them
to watch or you know i hope this doesn't
upset them too much because like i said
it really was a labor of love we were
trying to pay honor to the lakers and
pay honor to jerry buss
by telling the truth
it's great to talk to you john and you
did a wonderful job it's one of those
sometimes when you look at somebody and
you go i don't know is he going to look
like that guy and then after a while you
don't think about
oh is he going to look like that guy and
you know that's a that's a credit to who
you are and and what you do so thanks
for joining us and congrats on the
success
thank you very much i hope you enjoy the
rest of it that is john c reilly winning
time the rise of the lakers dynasty airs
this sunday at nine eastern on hvo